[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Septic tanks are
the perfect sewage treatment
solution for houses that aren't
connected to a sewage network.
The tank collects and
treats domestic wastewater
using a bacterial process
to decompose waste.
It filters the dirty
water before recycling
it back into the ground.
Septic tanks are
usually made of concrete
and have access covers on top.
The waste treatment
process takes place
in separate chambers
inside the tank.
Steel bars called
rebars reinforce the
concrete structure of the tank.
A welder assembles the
rods to form a cage,
then he spot welds the rebar
with a mid welding torch.
The welded cage will maintain
the structural integrity
of the concrete septic tank.
The welder measures
the cage's diagonals
to make sure it's straight.
Next, the worker
places rebar spacers
to keep the cage centered in the
mold and leveled on the floor.
A crane lowers the cage
into a custom formwork made
of high strength steel plates.
Workers close the
walls around the form
and secure them in place
with heavy duty locks.
The crane lowers
machined steel cores
to form the interior walls
of the tank chambers.
A rigid plastic tube is
inserted inside a rubber sleeve
to create a flow hole
between chambers.
Using an acetylene
torch, a worker
cuts holes in the rebar
for access openings.
The mold allows concrete
to flow over the rebar
and inbed the access opening
covers in the septic tank lid.
Workers pour over 1,300 gallons
of wet concrete into the mold.
They use a stick vibrator
to eliminate air pockets
and level the walls
with the putty knife.
Next, they mix more
concrete and pour
it over the top slab rebar.
Concrete blocks are used to
keep the plastic covers from
floating in the wet concrete.
While one worker pours
the concrete in the mold,
the other consolidates the
mixture with a vibrating stick.
Then a worker levels at the top
of the slab with the trowel.
Once the concrete tank has
cured, workers strip the forms.
They removed the concrete
tank using an overhead crane
and a compressed air system,
which forces the mold away
from the concrete tank.
The crane takes the strip
core away for cleanup.
A worker brushes
the top of the walls
and sweeps the floor
inside the tank
then he applies a butel
rubber tape around the top
of the exterior wall.
This forms a watertight seal
between the tank and the lid.
An overhead crane lifts
the lid out of the formwork
and brings it to the tank mold.
The crane slowly lowers
the lid onto the tank.
Workers keep it align to
make sure it seals properly.
Then they label the tank
to indicate its capacity.
Next, the mold is
opened, revealing
a finished septic tank.
The rubber sleeve
molded into the wall
ensures a watertight connection
between the pipe carrying waste
from the home and the tank.
This tank is now
ready for delivery.
They set the tank in the
ground at the client's
home using a radio remote
controlled knuckle boom crane.
A septic tank like
this will provide
a three bedroom
house with a fully
independent sewage system.
[MUSIC PLAYING]